>> Chris: TIME TO PLAY AWKWARD
ALBUM COVERS.
HERE IT IS.
YOU SHOULD NEVER JUDGE A BOOK BY
IT'S COVER.
BUT YOU SHOULD DEFINITELY JUDGE
A BAND BY THEIR ALBUM COVER.
I'M GONNA SHOW YOU SOME EXAMPLES
OF LAUGHABLY BAD ALBUMS, AND FOR
250 POINTS, I WANT YOU TO GIVE
ME THE NAME OF THE FIRST SINGLE
OFF THE ALBUM.
OKAY, FIRST ONE: THIS SURE-FIRE
PANTY-DROPPER FROM BRAINSTORM.
YES, JONAH.
>> COCK'S IN THE CRADLE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
ALI.
>> TUCK IT IN, TUCK IT IN.
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> DID THE WIDE-EYED GUY JUST
REALIZE WHAT HE'S DOING?
>> Chris: I THINK WHATEVER HE
WAS ON BEFORE JUST WORE OFF.
WHAT!
ALRIGHT.
NEXT ONE --
THIS GRIZZLY BALLER.
HEY, BIG BEAR WHAT YOU DOING.
THANGS.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: ALRIGHT.
ALI.
>> BITCH BETTER HAVE MY HONEY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE --
THIS CLASSIC FROM QUIM
BARREIROS.
JONAH.
>> MY FAVORITE WAS SQUEEZE BOX
FEATURING DEEZ NUTS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
I THINK IT'S DES NOTS.
BEN.
>> THE WORLD ACCORDION-ING TO MY
DICK.
>> Chris: POINTS.
POINTS.
LAST ONE, LAST ONE --
THIS HOOPS STAR.
COME ON.
THIS REMINDS ME, I THINK --
DIDN'T THEY JUST OPEN A DUNKIN'
HONUTS, LIKE, RIGHT ACROSS TOWN?
LIKE, THE LINES ARE CRAZY .
>> ALL THEY SELL ARE BOSTON
CREAMERS.
>> Chris: 100 POINTS FOR JONAH
RAY.
WHAT'S THE TRACK TO THIS ALBUM?
ALI.
>> INTRO TO WOMENS STUDIES.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]